in exceptionally cold regions freak  atmospheric conditions can sometimes  combine to produce perfect circle's of  ice and ice circle is a natural  phenomena created in a portion of the  lake that is a small Eddy that's  rotating sometimes the center of that  Eddy can have a little mass of ice well  as it spins it's cooling the water down  right next to it so that new ice forms  on the edges of the disc and if the  water conditions are perfect that new  ice creates a slightly bigger disc and  that as it continues to rotate and cool  the water down it can become a rather  large disc rotating in a very still lake  and it's one of the coolest natural  phenomenons that I've ever seen pictures  you